every time i've lost doe and i've lost
plenty luckily i've had more successes
than failures
is when i didn't listen to my gut which
is my experience
you think that you've come here and
you've got an mba
and you're going to go out in the world
and you're going to rock and you're
going to be
incredibly successful i've got news for
you for two-thirds of you
the world is gonna chew you up and spit
you out
you know i've learned a lot from the uh
ceos i've invested in over the years and
there was a woman
um a few years ago much more probably 10
years ago now
and she said to me something really
interesting i asked her why she was so
successful because she was
she said i do something very ordinary
and almost boring but i do it every day
she takes a
a sticky note and she writes three
things she has to get done before she
texts
answers any calls or does anything else
just three things and she sticks it on
the mirror
where she puts her makeup on and
she really it doesn't have to be
business things it can be
whatever it is that are deemed to be
important
to get done the next day maybe it's
something that's a holdover from the day
before because i've been doing this now
for years
and it's really effective this isn't
tech you're not putting it in your phone
it's not a software program
it's a piece of paper with and you have
it you know right
when you're going to bed brushing your
teeth whatever you write those three
things down you stick it on the mirror
i do it every night and then i am
myopically focused to get those three
things done
right before i do
anything else i nail those three things
you cannot believe
how productive you get when that happens
because you don't let the distractions
of all the other crap that's happening
around you
i just don't do it until i get the three
things done
and it's incredibly powerful i tell
people to try it most people try it get
stuck on it and they stick with it
it's really because in life there's so
much noise coming at you and every year
more noise and all kinds of different
distractions
and you always say to yourself well i
can multitask but you deemed that thing
to be very important and you ignored it
now it's three in the afternoon you're
exhausted
or you're busy with other stuff and you
say oh [ __ ] i didn't get that done and
it's
whatever whatever the effects the domino
effects are they're going to hurt you
and that's why i tell people try it out
it's a really great tool
okay that's number one what's uh what's
the second big habit
okay so this one's a little funky
chicken um it comes with a story okay
um when i was you know i wanted to be a
photographer or
a musician a rock star when i was you
know graduate when i got out of high
school and my dad my stepdad said me
you're not good you're not good enough
at either of those you'll starve to
death
if i if i were you i would go get any
kind of a degree
and focus on business which what i did
you know i didn't know what i wanted to
do but i learned some stuff
and i ended up going into postgraduate i
went and got an mba which was at that
time was a two-year program
which you know we can talk about the
merits of that or not because i've come
to realize what it was worth and what it
wasn't worth
but anyways i remember on the last week
um the graduating class and in those
it's sort of like an
amphitheater with about 100 people in it
and you've been there for two years
you've got your little name plate in
front
and they bring in guest lecturers to
talk to you before you jump into the
real world
and this guy comes in and he says
i'll never forget it he doesn't he walks
up
that the professor hands him the floor
and he just goes in the middle and just
looks up at everybody
for maybe like it felt like forever but
it was really
maybe 60 seconds didn't say a word and
the whole room
like you could have heard a pin drop
i'll never forget it and then
he says you guys think you're so hot
you think that you've come here and
you've got an mba
and you're going to go out in the world
and you're going to rock and you're
going to be
incredibly successful i've got news for
you for two-thirds of you
the world is going to chew you up and
spit you out you have
no idea what's going to happen to you
you are so
irrelevant you have proven nothing
you've done nothing
you think an mba means something it's
worthless and i remember
the guy beside me i've been beside me
for two years
i i we were up in the one road down from
the top so we can chat all the time
hide a little bit yeah yeah yeah and so
i said to him
barry was his name i said barry this guy
is such a
what an what an
he is what an arrogant actually is
well guess what he was right he was 100
percent right
and the reason he pointed that out was
the idea that
your experiences make you who you are
over time
as an entrepreneur as a parent as a
person as whatever you are as a brand
whatever you
are it's your experiences and how you
deal with them that gives you that
equity over time
and for many people they can't make it
it doesn't work out for them
they don't have what it takes to take on
the abuse that the world's
gonna throw at you and just to give you
full circle in a kumbaya you know
circle of life lion king kind of moment
i got caught saying the same thing a
couple of months ago at the harvard mba
group
i and i realized i was saying the same
thing that that guy said to me
decades ago i said to these kids you're
all
think you're you're harvard mbas you are
nothing burgers
you are nothing and and and so there you
have it
what he really explained was the idea of
experience and how you have to listen to
your gut
to navigate the bombs of your career and
you have to trust it you have to trust
your gut
every time i've lost dough every time
and i've lost plenty luckily i've had
more successes than failures
is when i didn't listen to my gut which
is my experience
and i shouldn't he was right he was
absolutely right
it was great information but i couldn't
assimilate it because i couldn't
put it in context now i understand it so
number two is
you need to build that experience and
all the way through
listen to your gut even when you're
young your gut will tell you you'll know
when it's right and wrong
and don't go against your intuition that
is actually
your radar that's your dna speaking to
you figuring out what the next move is
going to be
that's a powerful story yeah did they
say the same thing to you
in the back of the room and say what an
atlas guy is when you gave him the
speech at harvard
yeah the well it's um matt higgins who
was a get your shot i know
very well yeah yeah so matt um he he
emailed me the next day and said hey
kevin
i got to tell you you're a disturber i
mean you know
but you know much of the class really
enjoyed it but what he was really saying
is he pissed a few people off
yeah but you know i know higgins pretty
well we're good friends and so
you know he's uh you know he's he's
really savvy at what he does we wanted
to talk about direct to consumer
branding
and that's what we were doing in that
lesson was two hours it was great
uh i i work with that guy anytime he's
terrific yeah great guy
uh great content on linkedin he has he's
always sharing that content with me
there
um and the third habit that makes you
very successful
well you know it it's um you have to
make time
in your life for your significant other
and your family and it's very hard to do
it's extremely hard to do because you
when you
this is really speaking to more to the
entrepreneurial uh
community out there which is basically a
third of people one-third will attempt
to
take the entrepreneurial journey it's
not a destination is a journey and the
challenges
of that are very very difficult
particularly when you're starting out
and i learned this the hard way and
again i'm going to go to a story of a
class that i i taught years ago in the
evening class this is
this really sums it up it tells you
how important this is um three hour
class
six to nine we're almost closing you
know how
ten minutes left this guy hadn't said a
word the whole class
he finally puts up his hand and he says
um
listen mr wonderful um i have a question
for you it's not about the case what's
the case we're doing
i need some advice i said okay you know
you really haven't participated at all i
was kind of a little condescending
because i know you guys kind of know
who's who's engaged in the class
even though it was a huge cohort i think
it was something like 300 400 i can't
remember was a lot of people
anyways um he said i ha
i'm a i'm graduating this year i'm an
engineer and i've developed
a cloud-based software
enterprise system that helps hedge funds
with less than 250 million dollars
be compliant it's and you know it's very
difficult
to stay compliant when you're small he
needs two and 20 hedge funds
and his it was a subscription service so
these guys could use it on a cloud basis
and he he had written this code while he
was graduating in engineering
wow and he was his run rate was 5
million bucks a year in subscriptions i
mean that is like
and i said i don't hear a problem here i
hear something incredible going on
this is amazing and he said well here's
the problem my fiancee
came to me this morning and i'm really
deserving she said i have to make a
choice
she can't live with me anymore i never
attend any of her family's picnics i
never see anybody on weekends
i'm either studying or i'm working on
the code that's all i can do
and i asked her to come over and sleep
with me when she can and we'd be
together
but i'm just buried in this and i need
to do both i need to get my
graduation in engineering and i need to
keep my customers happy because this is
my business
now he said what do i do
rooms like this is getting interesting
right i mean
i said okay
which one is easier to replace
your business or your fiance
and that was probably not the right
thing to say
at the time but that's what i was
thinking in my head and i think
everybody else was too
this guy's phenomenally successful
clearly has gotten engaged to the wrong
person
that can't take that journey with him
most likely outcome is divorce
after they marry because he's going to
work 25 hours a day
eight days a week because he's got a
business he's an entrepreneur
my point is one of the biggest decisions
you're going to make in your life
between success and failure as a person
is finding that right
partner that you know i don't care you
know
who that is if you're going to take that
route
they have to be in sync with who you are
you can't
contort yourself to something else and
and i think that
a lot of people in their 20s really
should think this through
because you know not i told you i'm in
the wedding industry i've got a lot of
companies and i've learned a lot about
marriages the reason marriages fail is
not because of infidelity any marriage
can survive that i talked about it
earlier
but why they fail while the union breaks
up 50 of the time within five years
is financial stress one outspends the
other they're not in sync together they
don't share each other's goals
that's the hardest time in your life in
your 20s maybe start a family whatever
you're going to do
the point is picking that partner
is the third thing you either do right
or you do wrong
divorce is incredibly stressful
many people try it three four times
they're not in sync with their partner
i'm just you know this is kind of like a
little dr phyllis in some ways but i'm
telling you
with the ceos i work with and all the
investors i work with
i see stress in people when their
relationships are falling apart and it's
devastating
so there's a story there's a those are
the three things i care about
in giving guidance and i think everybody
knows what i'm talking about
and should think about these these are
powerful stories and i'm curious
uh love and money is such an interesting
topic because
most people disagree on it or one person
is outspending and then they get
divorced
one of the main reasons is money what
questions
should partners be asking each other
before they get married
around money how honest should they be
and
what if they have a massive disconnect
around money but they have this
intimacy and connection and love should
they you know just break up before the
wedding or what do you think
would be the right move to make
so i i have given a lot of guidance in
this space in fact i've written three
books about it
called men women and money men women and
children it's all kinds of advice about
family but here's here's how the journey
works you meet somebody
it's a great first date you have a
second date it's even better
okay by the time you're having your
third date
the only reason you're having your third
date is both of you are very interested
in each other
mm-hmm and that is the time to start
talking about the future
i know that sounds corny and i
understand third date if you're just
hooking up for hooking up i get it you
don't have to worry about this but if
you're
actually stopping seeing anybody else
and you're on your third date with
somebody you've met
and they've done the same thing and
you're being honest with each other
something's going on okay now it's time
to start
doing a little due diligence because
this is going to get serious
by the fourth date and you're not seeing
anybody else and you're talking about
you know
doing whatever you're going to do
together it's a big deal and you have to
understand
a little bit about where their heads are
at number one is
you know talk about family do you want
to have one
i mean you know it's a question some
people don't you got to know that up
front you make a decision about it or
can you have one it's a discussion got
to have
tough discussion again staying honest
number two
what are your goals how do you see
yourself in 10 years
are you at home are you working or would
you be raising kids i know this sounds
corny but believe me
women want that question and men want it
to
if you're on your fourth date they're
dying to get into this because they're
starting to really invest their time
in what they think they're going to be
anybody in your family bankrupt tough
question
ooh tough question have you ever been
bankrupt
then you ask how much do how much debt
to have on your credit card
tough question do you pay off your
credit card every month
oh my god and then they say why are you
asking me and if they say why are you
asking me this question you say
why can't you answer that what makes you
feel uncomfortable about this question
yeah well
what i really i really worry that the
reason you know you've got to be in sync
with some
the great here's the thing about
marriage about getting together whether
you're married or not or whoever
your significant other is if those are
aligned
if you have an understanding of each
other that is in sync
that union could last 50 years because
after the euphoria is over with you're
in business with each other you have to
build a financial pillar
to support growing old together or
raising a family or buying a house or
doing whatever you're going to do
and you need to be in sync on that stuff
and
this is a tough but i'll tell you
something
every every man and woman i've talked to
about this and when i was researching my
books all three of them
i was amazed at how forthcoming people
would be and say i'm dying to answer
that question i'm dying to ask that
question
i'm on my fourth date i really want to
know that about my potential partner
because i'm really interested in this
person and
i think we could be great together and
at least i'd like to try it but i gotta
know these things they're tough
questions
and you and and if if you like the
answers then you should feel encouraged
to
keep going and if you don't like them
you really have to do some soul
searching because
high probability at least 50 percent
it's not going to work out
this is interesting and what if someone
doesn't share the same
money mindset values as you do but
you're so in love with them that you
have this incredible connection
you just laugh at everything that you
guys share you know everything is easy
except for that one thing do you still
think there's a potential you could
work on that or is it hey if they don't
have the mindset now they're never gonna
have it
if they don't have the mindset now
they're never gonna have it you know
what you gotta do you gotta move on
tough really tough because it'll only
end in misery
you know i always say this people
say to me all the time what a cold
heartless
you are talking about love this way
it's not about money and i say oh yeah
it's always about the money
the reason people break up you'll find
out is always about money
it's always about money it's not about
it at the root of every divorce i'll
show you money
it won't be because they screwed around
you know it's really
some stress that's occurred within the
family because of financial
and look i'm just telling you the truth
i've already i started our conversation
saying i was going to do that and you're
going to get all kinds of people
listening to say what a
why don't i'm 100 right
and you know i've been around long
enough watching this happen to so many
people that i want to give them good
advice and i'm giving them good advice
you really have to get this bedrock
nailed down you really do
and particularly if you're into your
second year with somebody you know and
usually what happens is relationships
get intense they then become
you know um they agree that they're
going to be
just with each other which is a very
encouraging sign
and then they may go on for another year
or so before they tie the knot or maybe
they're never going to tie the knob but
the point is
they move in together they start buying
assets together you've got to get the
financial thing nailed down
if you like that video wait till you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe